hello my name is mikoy bianchik from
warsaw and in this tutorial i'd like to
give you a little bit of an overview of
algorithms for logic and computer
science
mainly those algorithms which are
influenced
by automata tutorial is going to be
organized around
two decision problems for logics
satisfiability and model checking
and when i talk about logic in this
tutorial i will mainly mean
first order logic and it's a variant
such as monolithic second order logic so
rather expressive
logics with quantifiers so the first
problem is
satisfiability and you want to know
if you're given a formula and you want
to know if the formula
is true in some model perhaps restricted
to some class of models
so as i mentioned i would be mainly
caring about this
the case when phi is of a formula first
order logic
or some ritual logics and here it is not
even clear
if this is a decided problem and as you
probably know
in unrestricted case it is an
undecidable problem
so it might be a little bit embarrassing
because this is a this tutorial is
partly devoted to
to the attendance of the sat
semester and in which case of course you
are dealing with statistical ability but
this is not the kind of
society that i will study here so i will
study satisfiability
for uh first order logic and and and
more powerful ones
and not for boolean propositional
formulas
and then the second variant is model
checking where you are now both the
model and the formula and you just want
to know if the formula
is true in the model the model checking
can uh can have a several variants and
and all of these will be discussed here
uh so the first one is
that in the algorithm the model m is
fixed and the formula phi is the input
of the algorithm
this will be most interesting for the
case when the
model is an infinite model and and
therefore it is not even clear how you
should
why this problem should be decidable the
second
case is where both the model and the
formula are the input
i will have the least or almost nothing
to say about this particular problem
and then the final problem is where you
fix the formula
and you uh are given the
model m on input and this will be most
interesting if
if you restrict m to come from some
restricted classes of models such as
models which are sparse and there's been
quite a lot of activity
about this in in the last few years
so in uh there were going to be three
parts of the tutorial
the first part which is now is going to
be
about checking uh the first order
formulas
or or variance or secondary formulas
which are true in a fixed structure
and the second part is going to be about
satisfiability
and the third part is going to be about
the variant of model checking on
restricted
classes of models and as i said i will i
will not
say almost anything about the the
problem where both the formula
and the model are given as input
so let's go straight to part one and the
other two parts you will
find in separate presentations
so i will begin with studying which
formulas of
first order logic are true in a fixed
structure
i i assume that you are familiar with
the syntax and semantics of first order
logic and anyway these are quite
natural so even if you're not you can uh
even if you do not have a formal
education in logic this should be kind
of clear so these are formulas
where you have quantifiers which range
over
elements of the input structure and
you're allowed to talk about the
relations and functions which are
defined in the input structure so
the blue example formula here it
says that the relation r is in fact a
function
because for every element of the
structure x there exists a y which is
related to it and in fact this y is
unique because for all other sets
which are related to they're equal to y
and
uh the problem that i would be caring
about is uh
well trying to understand which
structures or models i
use these words intentionally have the
following problem being decidable
you the structure m is fixed and you are
given
a first order formula of logic without
any free variables so
it's a sentence and such a sentence is
either true or false in the model
and the purpose of the algorithm is to
decide whether or not it is true
and this is a call this is
called deciding the first order theory
of the model because the first order
theory of a model is it's just a
set of sentences which are true in it it
is also traditionally used to be known
as
the elementary theory of a model because
elementary logic was just
another name for first order logic kind
of nice name actually i don't know why
it's
fallen out of use and let's begin
uh with uh the most simple
non-trivial examples so we want to
decide the first order theory
of a structure which has two elements
zero and one
and it has no other relations or no
relations or functions on it
the only thing it does have is equality
so our formulas are going to be able to
quantify over the elements
of the structure which are zero or one
and they will be allowed to
compare these elements for equality and
that's all you will be able to do
so how hard is it to decide if a formula
5 is true here so
what can you say with a first order
sentence when you have just access to
two elements and you can only compare
them for equality
so here's an example of a simple formula
it says that there is some x which is
equal to all
elements uh this formula would only be
true in
a model which has just one element and
since
zero one has two elements the formula is
not true and in fact this kind of
expressive power is
all you need uh to get p space
completeness
so uh using these kind of formulas we
will be able to
encode the quantified boolean formulas
remember if you remember quantified
boolean formulas
are formulas where your variables range
over values true or false and once
you've quantified over all your
variables you're allowed to write a
propositional formula as in this sat
problem
so uh you can easily encode a qbf
formula
in a first order sentence uh with
equality
the idea is that uh true will be
represent element of the formula at the
beginning this red
t and then the true variables are those
which are equal to t
and the false variables are those which
are not equal to t
so you uh you add one extra
variable t and then replace the
proposition
in the propositional formula x you
replace it by x equals two
and uh not x you replace it by x not
equals to t
and from this we can conclude that for
every finite
model m not just zero one equality omni
the its first order theory is p space
complete so the decision problem of
for the fixed structure m of deciding if
a given
sentence is true is b space complete and
this is because
p space hardness works already with the
simplest model where you have just two
elements and equality only
and on the other hand membership in p
space
for every finite structure is witnessed
by
the naive algorithm which just uh goes
for you know for every
when you have a quantifier it is a for
loop which checks
all possible values
and and then since you need a polynomial
it will in fact uh logarithmic space to
store an individual
element but but there might be
polynomial many of them give the
formulas long
uh then you just run the obvious
algorithm and it takes polynomial space
so this is rather simple so if the model
m
is finite and fixed uh then no matter
what it is at least
as long as it's not completely trivial
in the sense of having just one element
then it's first order theory is p space
complete
so that was a rather easy case
but the the problem is is interesting
not for finite models but it is
interesting for
infinite so what kind of infrastructures
are we going to discuss well the most
famous one is going to be arithmetic and
this is a famous
uh structure which is famous for having
undecidable first orders here
but there will also be other structures
and these are the ones that i will be
focusing on
where the first order theory is in fact
decided
and maybe one of the oldest ones is
etarsky arithmetic so this is the real
numbers with additional multiplication
and as it turns out uh although
superficially it might seem to be more
complicated because there's more real
numbers than natural numbers
it does in fact turn out that the first
order theory of this structure
is decidable because they are better
behaved than natural numbers
and then another example which is also
has been very influential in
in in computer science applications
is press bulgar arithmetic so you keep
the natural numbers which are kind of
badly behaved with respect to arithmetic
but you keep addition only there's
another example which is it's column
arithmetic which is natural numbers with
multiplication only and no addition this
is also decidable
but i will not discuss that at the
moment
so let's begin with arithmetic uh so uh
the famous
theorem this was already proved by by by
church this is the the original
undecidable
uh problem uh it says that the first
order theory
of arithmetic is undecidable and this
was proved in 1935.
and let me just give you a brief uh
proof sketch i will not go into the
details the idea is
that you can use the the central insight
is that you can use one number to
represent a
list of numbers so the way you do it is
if if you think of a decomposition
of a a natural number into its primes
prime factors then you have a list of
numbers there so it's this
uh the power of the first prime two the
power of the second prime three the
power of the third prime five and so on
this allows you to represent in a
one-to-one way
a list of numbers uh with numbers
and then uh that the main thing is that
this representation not only does it
exist but it can be
uh formalizing first order logic so list
operations such as taking the head of a
list so you input
one list and your one number which
represents a list and you output
another number which represents the
first natural number on the
corresponding list
or list concatenation where you input
two lists
represented as numbers and you output
another list represents there's a number
which is their concatenation all of this
can be done first of the logic so for
head it's kind of easy
you just check the highest power of 2
which divides your input number
for this concatenation uh you need to do
a little bit
of effort uh but i will not go into that
but i think you can figure it out
if you think about it unless uh you
haven't seen it for example with a
goddess
and once you get you can represent lists
and you can do list operations on them
in first order logic
then you can uh just simply formalize
the fact that a turing machine
has an accepting computation because a
list can be viewed as
a a list a
as a configuration of a machine and then
a list of lists so a list of
configurations is a computation and then
you can write the first four order
formula
which tells you that a list of
configurations is a
computation and hence you can write for
every turing machine you can write the
formula which is true
if and only if that turing machine has
an accepting computation
uh so uh this is a well
it's not exactly how church proved it
but it's it's it's it's
it is that the idea that how you could
prove it
now and uh and hence the first order
theory of the natural numbers
is inside the world so there is no
algorithm which decides
that and just in case you don't
notice it's it's it's amusing to know
that
it is already undecidable for very
simple first order formulas
uh namely for uh existential only
formulas
and this is because of the famous
undecidability result about little birds
10
problem so if you might if you don't
remember
herbert's 10th problem can be stated as
follows you are given a
polynomial p with a integer
coefficients and n variables and you
want to know
if you can instantiate the variables
using natural numbers
so that the result the value of the
polynomial is zero so in other words
does the polynomial have some natural
root uh you could also have an
a state an equivalent statement which
would be
where you ask about an integer root so
the x i's would be
not necessarily positive integers and
this is
uh equidiscible because every
integer can be represented as a
difference of two natural numbers and
conversely every natural numbers can be
expressed as a square
of a as a sum of the squares of uh four
integers
and and and therefore above both
variants of the problem where you ask
for integer or natural roots uh are
equidisible
and in fact they are both undecidable so
this is a famous
uh result that was proved by
martin davis hillary putnam julia
robinson
and matthias
so you can see that this is a special
case of existential because it's just
that the question itself is just an
existence routine
and actually if you uh
if you uh think about the proof
it shows a a even slightly a stronger
result namely
that if you uh if you take a polynomial
and you fix all variables except for one
of them and
and therefore and the the non-fixed
variables are
quantified existentially so this defines
a property
of natural numbers and in fact they show
that you can get every
recursively enumerable set this way so
for example
because the set of prime numbers is
recursively enumerable it follows that
there is a polynomial
which is zero exactly
on uh on the prime numbers and non-zero
otherwise it's a polynomial of
parameters which are existentially
quantified
another a funny corollary of of this
undecidability result this is again
this is a purely generic corollary of
any undecidable problem
is as follows so there is a polynomial
uh such that whether or not this
polynomial has
a yes answer to hilbert's 10th problem
so
whether or not it has an integer
a natural root
this statement can neither be proven or
disproved using
the axioms of say tremelo franco set
theory with choice
or in fact any formal system and and and
this is because of a generic result
which says that
for every undecidable problem you can
find an instance of the problem such
that whether or not
it is a yes or no instance is is
this is a independent of the axioms and
the reason for that is kind of simple
because
if all instances would be dependent then
just searching for proofs in in the
formal system
would be an algorithm and i think it's
kind of a little bit
mind-blowing that you can find a
polynomial such that you will
never establish whether or not it has an
integer root
or a natural root or not so now let's
move
to a structure which does have a decide
with first order theory
and one of the most early
and famous examples of such a structure
is the real numbers with
additional multiplication also known as
tarsky arithmetic
so task improved there were in roughly
19
in the late 20s but the the the
published version was
after the war he proved that
the first order theory of the field of
real numbers
is decidable and the method that he used
has been very influential influential
later on
which is called the method of quantifier
elimination so what he showed
is that for every first order formula
possibly with
three variables they're existing and can
be computed
an equivalent formula that does not use
any quantifiers
now if you want to eliminate quantifiers
you have to be careful about the
functions and relations that are
given in the logic so because for
example
0 can be defined in terms of additional
multiplication by saying
that this is the neutral element of
addition but of course this definition
uses a
quantifiers because it says that for
every x
x plus 0 equals x and if we care about
quantifier-free formulas
then we need to be a little bit more
careful and
uh so we add zero and one we treat
addition and
multiplication and subtraction actually
we'll also add it and we treat all of
these as
as relation as functions not with
relation so addition is a binary
function
and we also have the order the order is
kind of important
in tarsky's proof and
because the real numbers are an ordered
field
and if you think about the complex
numbers they do not have an
order one can show this uh but their
first order is also
first order theory is also decidable and
in fact also thanks to quantifier
elimination now
once you have proved that you can
eliminate quantifiers
then you get the decidability because
what you do is you take
a sentence you keep you eliminate all of
its quantifiers so you get a sentence
which does not have quantifiers and
what can sort the sentence be it can be
just a statement which is constructed
from zero and one
using the uh the the field operations
and then these things can be compared
for order
and and and then and for such a first
order sentence you can
easily decide if it is true so so to
illustrate
uh the quantifier elimination
phenomenon consider the following
school-like example
where you have a formula phi which has a
four variables so three of them
are free so abc and the fourth one x is
bound and the formula says
that there exists a real number x such
that a x squared plus b
x plus c is equals to zero so in other
words the a a b c represents a quadratic
polynomial
and the formula tells you if the
quadratic volume has a root or not
now according to a quantifier
elimination this formula is equivalent
to some quantifier free one
and in fact it is you might remember
this from your
school days uh the formula says that b
squared minus
four times ac is greater than or equal
to zero and if this is this is satisfied
if and only if the corresponding
quadratic polynomial has at least one
root
uh so a itarsky's elimination procedure
has
well gives you this so it has to be
somehow aware of this it also has to be
aware of this type of phenomenon for not
just for quadratic
polynomials but for cubic uh polynomials
and and
ones of higher degree and in each case
it gives you a quantifier free
a criterion of the coefficients of the
polynomial
which guarantee that it has at least one
root and in fact you can even uh
there's a there's a bit of a funny story
here
which is that tarsky in the time when he
was working on these results
to support himself he was working as a
teacher in a girl's secondary
school and so you can imagine that he
was
teaching things like dividing one
polynomial by another
or at least differentiating polynomials
and
if you look at his proof of quantifier
elimination then
this is actually the kind of things that
you do
so maybe he was just bored as a high
school
teacher and he just decided to do
something with that
scientifically and hence his algorithm
but this is just speculation and
i think it is probably not true
here's another example application of
tarski's quantifier elimination
procedure if you think about a
quantifier-free formula
with just one variable x then what it is
it is a boolean combination
of inequalities of the form some
polynomial is greater or equal to
zero and if it's a finite boolean
combination uh
then since every polynomial changes
sign finitely often then the formula
itself will change
uh truth values finitely often and hence
it's going to be
a finite union of intervals
closed open open closed and so on and in
particular
if you think about the property x is a
natural number then this property
changes
values infinitely often and therefore it
cannot be
defined in first order logic just using
the
field operations this is not so much of
a surprise because
if you would be able to define the fact
that a real number is
a a natural number then you could also
use tarsky's field of real numbers to
decide arithmetic because you would just
say
write any formula that you want to text
in our arithmetic and just relativize or
quantify to say that you only care about
those
variables x which are natural numbers
for similar reasons you can also not
express that a real number
is a rational number
and in fact also the variant
the field of rational numbers has an
undecidable first order theory
because in the field of rational numbers
you you can actually express that a
number
is a natural number and hence use on the
side of your
of arithmetic on the other hand the
field of complex numbers
is decidable as i mentioned before
because of quantifier
eliminate so let me move now to
uh another structure which has the
decide with first order theory and this
is present
arithmetic so it's somehow incomparable
with tarsky arithmetic because it is
easier because it does not have a
addition a multiplication but it is
harder because it uses the natural
numbers
instead of the real numbers so this is a
theorem that was approved by a major
express burger
in 1929 which says that the first order
theory of the natural numbers with
addition
only is decidable wesberger's original
proof
was a a variant of that was presented as
a variant of a quantifier elimination
because you can
show that this structure the first order
theory admits quantifier elimination
if you have a suitable signature
so you expand operations with operations
such as
a predicate which it tests if something
is dissolved by two or three and so on
and if you expand your signature enough
then you get quantifier elimination
i will present it however in a slightly
different way which which is also
consistent with
bulger's original solution but this is
the way that
many people think about it now so uh
what you can show
is that for every first order formula
again we care about formulas also with
free variables so not just sentences
which have no free variables
semantics of the formula so it's um an
nru relation on
natural numbers is the lemma says is
such
a relation is necessarily semi-linear so
what's a semilinear
set of tuples and tuples of natural
numbers
it is a set as in the red writing here
so you it's a it's a finite union of
linear sets and each linear set is
obtained by taking some
basic vector a zero it's an n tuple of
natural numbers
and then adding to it any
anything spanned by some k other
dimensional vectors but when you are
spanning here
it is you are your coefficients have to
be
natural numbers with non-negative
numbers so
any such set is called linear and the
final you
you so a basis plus a cone
span by some k some some vectors is
called a linear set and then a finite
union of
such sets it's called semilinear so uh
what a presburger show is that
semi-linear sets are exactly those which
can be defined in press
arithmetic so
let's let's prove that every formula
does indeed
define a semi linear set uh i will not
prove to you the main lemma but what i
will
explain is the structure of the proof
because this kind of structure of proof
will be
visible many times later in this lecture
so it's just uh an induction on the size
of the formula
so let's begin with a basic formula
which is uh
uh the the basic predicate which says
that uh
x1 plus x2 is equal to x3 or you know it
could be x5 plus x7 equals to x2
and and if you think about it this this
the the semantics of this formula so the
set of triples such that the first two
coordinates add up to the third one
is easily seen to be a semi-linear set
uh here the basis vector is is is is
zeros and it is just any vector which
can be obtained
uh by uh having a positive a
non-negative combination of the vector
one zero one
and zero one one so any because uh
uh you can easily see that this this
spans the vectors which
form a legal addition two parts so this
is a semi linear set
uh that that that takes well equality is
also a seminar set so the set of pairs
such that the first coordinates is equal
to the second coordinate is is semi
linear it is spanned by the vector one
comma one
and now uh you have to show that
semi-linear sets have all of the closure
properties that you
would have for a formula of first order
logic
so you can show that they're closing
their union this is almost by def
this is by definition because a semi
linear city that find a
union of linear sets so you just take
two finite unions you get another finite
union
there is projections which corresponds
to existential quantification i will
discuss this in a moment
and then there is a complementation so
uh let's uh see what what do i mean by
protection
and what is that why is that correspond
to existential quantification
so imagine you have a formula with
x plus one variable so you have one
variable y and then k
other variables so the semantics of this
formula is a is an arity on natural the
relation of natural numbers without
is x whose rt is k plus 1.
and now if you quantify this variable if
you play an
an existential quantifier then if you
think about the corresponding relation
the identity here is k because the the
number of
three variables is just k it it is the
same thing as
taking the original a k plus one array
relation
and projecting it to the coordinates x
one up to
x k and so erasing coordinate y so the
projection operation
it inputs a k plus one tuple and and it
outputs a k tuple which is
obtained by erasing the first coordinate
and
so existential quantification
for formulas on the sides of the
semantics is called corresponds to
taking
a relation of higher arity and
projecting the tuples in that relation
to some subset of coordinates by
eliminating the
existentially quantified coordinate i
say this here because
the idea that projection and existential
quantification
uh are the same thing will will appear
uh multiple
times later on in in this tutorial and
it is good to get used to it
in the most basic setup which is press
broker
arithmetic so uh you can rather easily
see that semi-linear sets are closed
under projection so you need to show is
that the linear sets are closed under
projection and what you do is you just
look at all of the vectors
and you just eliminate the the the
coordinate that is being projected away
so that's rather simple
and uh the only remaining technical
thing to do is to prove
that semi-linear sets are closed under
complementation
now this can be done using a little bit
of modular arithmetic and
greatest common divisors and stuff like
that i don't want to get
into the details of this this would it
would be like
one or two slides because it is going to
be a little bit of the
central topic here uh and so i won't
discuss this in my tutorial
at any rate uh later on uh in this
lecture we're going to see
a complete and alternative decidability
proof
which will use automata so maybe i won't
need
a press broker's original proof these
are examples
of structures m and the complexity of
the
of deciding their first order theories
so
for any finite structure it's always
going to be space complete
for a the natural numbers and
additional multiplication also known as
arithmetic the problem is undecidable
but it is decidable for other cases such
as starsky arithmetic or prismulger
arithmetic
uh i just dis this the in the in the
cases of tarsky and prince booker i only
discussed uh
decidability but of course there's also
complete computational complexities
in involved and tarsky arithmetic is
known to be
in exponential space and i i believe it
is not known yet to be complete for
exponential space
while presburger arithmetic lies
somewhere between
non-deterministic double exponential
time and
doubly exponential space now in this
tutorial i will not be getting any more
examples of
structures with a decidable or
undecidable first order theory
and i will move towards direction which
is
more central for my tutorial which is
logics other than first order logic and
i will begin with
second order logic so second order logic
is like first order logic
but you're also allowed to quantify over
sets
or relations and also functions because
you can do a a function
as a set so let's overview the the
syntax
and semantics of second order logic so
you can write formulas here now you can
write special quantifiers which say
uh you have a quantifier which ranges
over elements this is the usual first
order quantification but you also have
quantifiers which range over say binary
relations
you have a quantifier which ranges over
unity relation
and so on so for every rtk you have a
quantifier ranges over kre relations i
used some syntax here with the
arity as a little subscript but i don't
think this is the
the actual syntax that you use for
second order logic
you cannot however con quantify over
third or
order objects such as sets of sets uh
or relations on sets or relations on
relations
that would only be allowed in in third
order logic
but i i discussed for the moment second
order
so here's a rather straightforward
theorem which says
that the complexity of deciding second
order logic is rather easy to understand
namely if you have a finite structure
then deciding
which second fixed finite structure then
this deciding
which second order sentences are true in
it is a piece-based complete problem
while if the structure is infinite then
its second order theory is undecidable
and this is rather easy to see why well
if you uh if your structure is finite
then p space hardness is inherited
already from first order logic and
uh in fact you don't even need to have a
universe which has
at least two elements because if you
have one element in your universe and
you still have get to have two sets the
empty set and the full set
so it's p space a hard already for
structures
every structure with with one or more
elements
let's say we disallow empty structures
and
uh the problem while pspace membership
still works using the naive algorithm
because
how do you check if
if there exists a relation well you can
just look through all possible relations
and so in order to store a single
relation you just need a polynomial
space
so doing a naive for loop across all
relations of fixed arity
is is going to be a p space algorithm
on the other hand for infinite
structures uh
you can you get no matter how simple
your infinite structure would be it
could have no relations whatsoever
ah the problem is
is still undecidable because you can
just write a formula
which embeds arithmetic in it by saying
you
just guess in the formula a set
of of triples which is meant to
represent
the addition uh relation in arithmetic
you
guess a set of triples which is meant to
eliminate represent the
multiplication uh relation and you say
that additional multiplication are what
they should be so you you write out uh
the ax there are some axioms which is
particularly in second order logic and
once you have arithmetic available
you can say that your turing machine
holds using the usual undecidability
proof
for arithmetic so here i implicitly
assume that the structure is countable
but you're gonna carve out a countable
subset in second order logic
quite easily so this is true for every
structure anyway summing up
second order logic is is it's rather
trivial to
classify its computation complexity
hence we could talk about something else
and it turns out actually that there is
some interesting
something else and this is a monadic
second order logic which is actually
going to be
somehow the main theme of my tutorial so
this is a logic which sits between
first order logic and second order logic
and it is the fragment of second order
logic
where you're not allowed to quantify
with binary or ternary relations or
relationship the only relations that you
are allowed to quantify over
are unary relations hence the name
monadic because monadic relations
is the same thing as universities
so what i would like to discuss now is
uh
try to understand the structures uh for
which their monadic second order theory
is decidable
and uh this turns out to be a a place
where automata it
are very important and hence i am very
happy to talk about it
so let's begin with a simple toy example
namely the mso
theory of the simplest possible infinite
structure so you have an infinite
universe the natural numbers
but you have no no no no relations on it
except for equality which you
you need to have uh at least in this
talk
and uh i claim that uh here the mso
theory is decidable and it's because of
quantifier elimination
so imagine you have a formula of monadic
second order logic
which uses this infinite universe and
has equality
so the formula might have some free
variables some of them might be
first order variables so they describe
elements
some natural numbers and some of them
might be second or monadic second order
variables and therefore they describe
sets of natural numbers possibly
infinite sets
now if you think a little bit about it
there's not much you can say with
equality only
and in fact one can show that
the only things you can say is that an
element belongs to a set
and a set has some size like
five or seven or the set
has some uh well co-finite size so it's
it's uh
it contains all but three elements and
these are the only things that you you
can say
and you can show that uh uh these
quantifier-free formulas would use
these basic uh formulas oh and equality
of course
as well are the only things that you can
express in this logic and this was
proved by induction formula size
so this has a decidable
mso theory and in particular if you have
an mso formula
which uses just the all of the three
variables
are first order variables
then it is equivalent to a quantifier
free uh
formula that uses just equality on these
these first order version okay that's
not very interesting
uh and but now we'll we'll move to some
more exciting example
so uh this the following question was
raised i think uh by
by tarski you can find this quote in in
a paper by raphael
robinson which says that it was alfred
tarski's idea
uh to discuss
an intermediate between first order and
second order definition
where you are allowed monadic second
order logic
and then the question uh that was asked
is
for monadic second order logic what
happens if you consider the natural
numbers with
with order and uh so the paper that of
robinson that i'm citing
it it showed that well maybe it didn't
give an answer to tarsky's original
question but it said that it becomes
already undecidable with mso
if you are allowed to uh double uh
numbers and and and then he asked you
know well but maybe is this is doubling
necessary
or not and it turned out to be actually
a very interesting adventure
which led to many results and then a
field that is active until uh today
uh so what i will be would begin with in
my discussion
is a a a first partial solution to
uh tarsky's question uh which is uh
not it's you we we keep the structure of
natural numbers with with order
uh but we only care about the weak mso
theory which i will discuss in a moment
and then uh but with the weak mso theory
turns out to be interesting in and of
itself
and then i will move to a description of
the actual solution of tarsky's problem
so what is this weak uh mso theory
the idea is that you write formulas
which have the same synthetic limits so
so you quantify over elements
and you quantify over sets as well but
the semantics of the set quantifier is
different
it means a finite set so for example if
you write a formula
which says that there exists a set which
contains
all possible elements all possible
natural numbers
then this formula is going to be true in
the usual mso because you can take the
set of all natural numbers
but in we can so it is not going to be
true because there is no
finite set which contains or natural
numbers so in principle it seems uh
that the two logics are incomparable but
in fact uh over the ordered natural
numbers it is rather easy to see that
weak mso can be
embedded in a usual full mso
in the following way uh you can write a
formula in
the usual mso where quantification is
over
unrestricted sets which says that i said
it's finite namely you say that
there is there is a largest there's a
finite upper
there's an element which would upper
bounds all elements of
the set and therefore if you want to
have weak quantification you can just
simulate it in usual mso by saying there
exists a set which has a finite
upper bound and therefore for every
formula of weak mso you can write an
equivalent one
in full mso and hence the problem for a
full mso it is
at least as hard as the one for weak
muscle
as it turns out using a non-trivial
automatic theory the converse is also
true
over the or well not over general
structures but over the ordered natural
numbers
for every formula of full mso there
exists an equivalent
formula of weak mso but this is a
non-trivial result and
i will not discuss it anyway
so what we care about now is uh deciding
weak mso
theory of the natural norms and it turns
out this is one of these
the oldest results in in automata theory
that the automata theory and logic
extremely
influential and seminal result which
says that
the weak mso theory of the natural
numbers is decidable
so let me give you a a proof of this
result which is going to be using
automata so
consider a formula of weak msl now it
might have several three variables in
this particular example it has one first
order variable x and two
set variables capital y and capital z
now in press burger when we discussed
press burger arithmetic we had some kind
of normal form which in the case of
prince bulgaria meticulous semi-linear
sets
which told us what are the kind of
things
kind of sets that you can get from
formulas so we are going to uh
aim for something similar for uh weak
mso
so we want to describe the relation
the semantics of this formula which in
this particular formula is a set of
triples a number
small x and two finite sets of numbers
a capital y and capital z so how do we
represent
this set of triplets well uh maybe it
would be a quantifier free formula
as in in task arithmetic this is we're
not going to do
maybe some kind of generalization of
semi-linear set
well if well the answer is we're going
to use an automaton maybe you could call
that a
semi-linear set if you wish so but i
don't think that would be very well
justified so the the big insight here
is that we can use an automaton to
represent
the semantics of a formula and this is
something that we will be
discussing many times in this tutorial
so how do you do this so imagine that
you have this uh
triple which is a one number small x and
two numbers capital
and capital z then you can view them as
a finite word
because uh you just write for every
natural number
uh is it equal to small x and does it
contain is it contained in capital one
capital z so you just write a plus means
it's
it's contained in and and and minus
means it's not contained
and since your sets are finite you can
just stop at
finitely many steps because from some
point on you will
in every column you will only see three
minuses so you
you use a finite word which for every
natural number has a column
consisting of minuses and pluses which
tells you which
uh which sets that natural number
belongs to
and which of the three variables it is
equal to
and and hence you can represent such a
finite sets and a num and several finite
sets and several finite numbers
as a finite word over an alphabet and in
general the alphabet is plus minus
to the power of well however many
numbers and sets you want to represent
and of course here if you want your
representation to be finite where it is
it is crucial
that you're dealing with a finite set
so once we have fixed uh finite words as
a representation
finite sets and numbers we can now
prove the following which says that for
every formula of weak mso
if you look at the corresponding
finite words which represent the
valuations which make this formula true
these are words over an alphabet plus
minus to the power of n
plus k where n is the number of first
order variables in case the number of
set variables then this is actually
a regular language and how do you prove
that
well uh it's just a simple induction
formula size
so let's begin with the atomic formulas
so what what
kind of formulas do you have well one is
one says that
a first order variable x i belongs to
a set variable xj
so what kind of language is that well
you have to have the words
such that in every column if you see a
plus on the
column if if in every column
if you see a plus corresponding to x i
then you also see a plus in the
column corresponding to xj so there's
just a finite automaton which looks
separately at every column and text if
it has this consistency property
it should also check that for every
first order variable
there is at most one column which
contains a plus in the corresponding row
and again this can be
tested by a finite automaton the other
type of atomic formula
is that x i is before x j and this is
just an automaton which takes what
it scans the columns of the word each
column contains pluses and minuses
and then it checks that if you see uh
the uh column
a letter which has xj a a
a plus on the in in the position
corresponding to variable xj
then you must have seen previously uh x
i
or or in the same column again this is a
a finite automaton which roughly just
checks that every
uh every appearances of some subset of
the alphabet
is is not before
appearances of some other subset of the
alphabet so you can write this using a
regular expression or an automaton
so we have proved that for the atomic
formulas
the corresponding properties of of words
are definable by automata and now
we can deal with boolean combinations
uh because of the fact that regular
languages languages defined by automata
are closed under boolean
operations so union complementation on
the other hand
if you have a existential quantifier
then the corresponding operation on
languages is projection as we have
discussed for
presburger arithmetic so the main
observation that you need is is the
following one which is a rather
straightforward observation on regular
languages
if you have a regular language over an
alphabet
where every letter is a pair and you
project away the
the second coordinate of the pair then
the resulting language is also regular
you should think of of the the pairs as
follows that the the
the variable that you're projecting the
part that you're projecting away
describes the
quantified set and closure on the
projection is rather easy to see
for regular languages one way to view it
is regular
expressions if you have a regular
expression which describes a set of pair
then you can just from the regular
expression you can replace every pair by
the
corresponding letter uh first coordinate
and
you have a regular expression which
describes uh the projection
another approach is to use
non-deterministic automata so
non-deterministic automata for the
projection uses non-determinism
to recognize uh to guess the missing
part of of the world
however uh there is a little bit of a
mismatch
between the type of representations that
we use for regular languages
to get the different parts of the proof
of this lemma
because if you want to do a
complementation
then you are you would like to be
working with deterministic automata and
not
non-deterministic automata or regular
expression
on the other hand as i have discussed
for projection
your preferred format would be a
non-deterministic automata or regular
expressions
and in fact uh it turns out that this is
a a a problem uh it is for the
complexity of the algorithm
because if you want to uh complement it
then it turns out that the only way you
can really do it is to
first determinize and then complement
and uh
and therefore if if your formula
alternates end times between
complementation and projection
then you will need to uh apply
determinization and times
resulting in an enfold exponential
automaton and by
need to uh what i mean is that the
complexity of the problem
is going to be enfold exponential in the
formula size in the
number of alternations that have been
described here
so that is the basic idea behind
deciding the ms weak mso theory of
natural numbers so
for a formula we represent which has
three variables we represented semantics
using an
automaton and then we observe that the
automata
have all of the closure properties which
are required of the logic
and this idea has proved to be
incredibly influential and i will just
discuss many other instances of it in my
tutorial and this is going
to be actually the central topic of my
tutorial
but before i do that uh
let me have some historical
remarks so in the theorem i gave a
number of names
and some of these if you're familiar
with the topic some of these you might
recognize but maybe some of these you
might not
so i i will make some historical remarks
here
so uh one of the names is a t which
stands for trachtenbrot
who was a at the time in the soviet
union
and he wrote in 1985
published in 1958 but but he submitted
in 1957
a paper uh who which is called about
which is called well here's is is this
the russian
name but it says that it is about the
synthesis of logical nets
where the operators are defined
in terms of formulas that use one place
uh
predicates so about uh in terms of of of
monadic second order logic so that was
uh
in the soviet union and in parallel uh
julius buchi and and and calvin elgot in
in the united states uh they also
announced the same result
in conference proceedings later they
wrote uh journal versions but for some
reasons
there were two separate eternal papers
but the original conference announcement
was uh
joined in in 1958 and in fact the
the the conference announcement the
proceedings version is short enough that
i can include it here
in its full body so here it is
it it can be found in the notices of the
ams and i have highlighted in blue
the the the main theorem which as you
can see it's uh
it it says that the main thing is not
the decidability of the theory but the
fact that the
the sets that you can represent are
exactly those that you can define using
a finite automat and then it is i think
this is
the way that this theorem has been
perceived ever since it's not really the
decidability of the theory but more
the insight into the fact that it can
only define finite automata describable
things
but if you look at the next line below
the part you will see here that actually
the result itself so the decided ability
of weak
mso over natural numbers so a partial
answer to tarsky's question
actually has been proved before and it
is a credited
to anja ellen freud and and vote and i
will discuss this
in a moment so it's a it's it's it's a
result which has
never been published as far as i know uh
and and which
proceeds at least being an elgata i'm
not sure about platinum but who was
working
uh in parallel so uh what what did aaron
feighton go to
is a nice story uh and if you want to
have a look at it in more detail i
recommend
that you read an article a column in the
signal siglock news nate letter from
2019 by wolfgang thomas and the story is
roughly speaking as follows
uh you can use ordinal numbers uh two
represents numbers and finite sets of
numbers how do you do that
well for this particular slide you're
i assume that you're familiar with a
little bit of organs
so uh uh here's an example of an ordinal
uh you can write omega to the power of
five
so this is a well-known a countable
ordinal er
it the the corresponding
well-ordered set is five tuples of
natural numbers ordered
lexicographically
and this number omega to the power of
five you can use it to represent the
number five
and then uh but you could you can
combine ordinals together using an
operation called ordinal addition
and this way you can represent a finite
sets of numbers so for example omega
to the power five plus omega squared
plus one
is a is a an ordinary there's a
there's a there's a it corresponds to a
lexicographically ordered set
and uh this you can view it as the
ordinary which consists of the number
five
two and well zero because uh one is
omega to the power of of zero
you could also represent some you know
maybe
sets with weights and so on but this is
not going to be uh used here so you can
view a finite you can represent a finite
set of numbers
as an ordinal number using ordinal
addition uh just uh if in case you're
not familiar with ordinals you have to
be careful
because ordinal addition is not
commutative
because if you add ordinary in the wrong
way then the bigger ordinals eat up the
smaller ones so you have to be careful
about the order in which you write
and if you use this a representation of
finite sets as
as ordinal numbers then the basic
operations that you want to do
on finite sets such as a membership of a
number in a finite set
and comparing two numbers for order
and taking boolean combinations of sets
all of this can be
defined using first order logic using
only the operation of
ordinal addition and uh
you only need a relatively small
original ordinals which are smaller than
omega to the power of omega which which
is roughly that the ordinal type
described here so
finite the ordinal addition applied to
finite numbers
uh finite powers of omega and
and under ordinal additions and a
and j ellen proved in 1957
that this structure has decided first
order theory
and then what uh observed
that you can apply uh these results to
to to get mso in the way which is
roughly described
on this slide and if you want to have a
look at the details uh
as i said i recommend having a look at
the paper by
wolfgang thomas so in fact the the the
weak mso application
it it it predates the the automata
proof but it is the automata proof that
it turned out to have
a lasting value as you will see in the
later parts of my tutorial
but if we continue reading the beefy and
elgat abstract we read
we did one more interesting thing which
says
that the corollary of these results is
that a prince bulgaria arithmetic is
decidable
this this this abstract is written in a
rather dense
style so i'm not sure what r means here
but the presburger i guess it means
spread
so i think it's useful to uh to explain
how you can
deduce a presburger arithmetic from the
results that have been discussed here so
let's have a look at
that so uh
the idea is very simple uh if i want to
embed
a press burger arithmetic and weak mso i
i just use the obvious representation of
a number
as a it's it's binary expansion so if i
want to represent
uh the number 67 then i use the set 0
comma 1 comma 6 which is
the powers of two that participate
in the binary expansion of 67 and
if you uh represent numbers as finite
sets
via binary expansion then you can
implement
a in weak mso addition because if you
just try to think about
how you add two numbers then
this can be formulaized using weak mso
you just have to or or a finite
automaton if you prefer that
uh which reach the two sets with the
least
significant digit being given at the
beginning and it just the finite
automaton just needs to
scan the columns and check that
everything is correct locally and
maybe need to have one extra bit of
memory for the carry operation all of
this can be easily implemented by a
finite automaton
and also by a weak mso formula so a
corollary
is that uh for every formula of a press
burger arithmetic which is only allowed
to use addition
uh the corresponding n area addition
relation on numbers uh viewed as finite
sets
via binary expansion can be defined
defined in weak mso or equivalency can
be recognized by finite automata so this
is an alternative
normal form for pris-bulgur arithmetic
as opposed to semi-linear sets
of numbers we have regular languages
of binary representations
this uh so this is an alternative proof
for press bulgar arithmetic this
alternative proof it has the advantage
that it allows you to add some stuff to
press book arithmetic because for
example suppose that we extend
arithmetic with an extra predicate which
says that a number is a power of 2.
this is not expressible in in arithmetic
because the set of powers of 2 is not a
semi-linear set
but if you think about numbers which are
powers of two
given in binary expansions is easily a
regular language it just consists of
numbers
where there's just well a unique digit
is equal to one
and in fact uh you can go a little bit
beyond that
or you could use a ternary predicate
which says that
you were given two numbers y and z and
uh
you uh you say that x is the smallest
power
of two that divides both of them you can
also do this
using a a finite automaton you just look
at
the least significant
digit where both y and z have a one and
then
and x has to be the power of two which
corresponds to that digit
it's a little bit of a random and
arbitrary
predicate but it has the property
actually
that if you add this particular
predicate uh to press bulgaria
arithmetic
then you get all of the power of finite
automata and namely if you extend it
press burglar arithmetic with this
predicate the corresponding uh
nre relations on uh were say unary
relations on on
what energy relations on on on binary
expansions are going to be exactly the
regular ones
uh maybe it's worth pointing out that
some terminology if you want to look
things up later
that the fact that you can
uh take uh presbyter garyvee let's view
it as a group so it's integers possibly
negative ones the presburger's theorem
applies to possibly negative integers as
well
so uh then this is an example of an
automatic group
uh so an automatic group where there's
two views on the automatic group one of
them is that
you can represent in both cases you can
say that
the elements can be represented as a
strings over a finite alphabet
and then one approach is that the group
operation
it can be implemented by an automaton
and another one which is actually
more more popular is that
for every generator of the group the
unary operation of multiplying by that
generator
uh can be implemented by an automaton
and groups which can be represented this
way
are actually a legitimate topic of study
in group theory which was i think these
observations uh
there's a book by epstein and co-authors
and and he credits uh
that automata insight in group theory to
the great
geometer thurston and uh but
even beyond automatic groups you can
imagine just
automatic models and this is a notion
which was
based on automatic groups was introduced
by nerodian hussein of
uh and so what's an automatic structure
it's a structure where the underlying
set
is is is is a regular language so some
maybe not necessarily all strings over
some finite alphabet but
the strings which are in the underlying
set uh need to be a regular language
and then you want the the basic uh that
the
the relations in the structure to be
implementable by automata
and then uh using uh the proofs uh the
ideas that you can see on these slides
you can conclude that uh for every
automatic structure
uh not only are the relations be
definable by automata
uh as as assumed by the definition but
also every first order formula
is defined by an automaton and therefore
in particular the first order theory
is going to be uh decidable uh just on a
side about automatic groups
in case you are not confused enough by
the terminology there is also
an extra notion called an automaton
group which is also important in group
theory and
this is not the same thing as an
automatic group so an
automaton group consists is a group
which is obtained by taking some
transducers
implemented by certain kinds of automata
and as long as these
transducers are reversible then they
generate a group
and groups which are obtained this form
are called automaton groups and
and they have been used to for example
to provide a
counters examples
problem but this is just a an aside in
case you're interested in such things
so this completes my uh this discussion
of the
history and origins of the automata
method
in logic so that the main players here
are going to be bihi elgot and
trattenbrot who uh may have the the the
insight
that you can represent logical formulas
and the sets that they define
using automatic and
this method has proved to be incredibly
influential
and i will give to you some examples of
how how it has developed later
so the the next example is actually
about the
the full solution to the problem raised
by tarsky namely the
decider being the full theory of mso
over the natural numbers where you are
allowed to quantify over infinite cells
so this was proved by uh shortly where a
few years after
the result for weakness so so he proved
that
the full theory of full mso where
infinite sets are allowed
of the natural numbers with equality is
decidable and
it is actually the same proof as for
weak mso except
not now if you think about a formula
with three variables
then in order to describe the infinite
sets
that are used to instantiate the free
variables
you need to have infinite words so what
bihi did
is he defined a suitably extended
automata to infinite words and then he
developed the necessary automata theory
uh which was that the language is
recognized
by his extended automata for omega words
so infinite words
are closed under boolean operations and
production
and that is allowed him to prove that
the mso theory
the full msl theory decide so what are
these
omega automata automata over infinite
words now i know that there will be a
tutorial uh
tomorrow by uh well the next tutorial by
orna kupferman
about such things so i will not go into
too much detail but
at least i can give you an example so
these are automata which are called
non-deterministic piche automata and the
way it works is that you have
the same syntax as for a
non-deterministic finite automaton so
you have a set of states in this
particular example
there's two states a red state and a
blue state
and then there's some input there's some
initial states in this case
the red state is initial and some
accepting states in this
in this case the double circle indicates
that only the blue state
is accepting but in general it could be
any subset of states
likewise initial could be any subset of
states and then then you have the
transitions of the automaton and it is
non-deterministic because
you can observe if you're in the red
state and you read the letter a then you
can either stay in the red state or you
can go to the blue state
so this is just an nfa but
the semantics are different so you
run a non-deterministic brief automaton
you run it on an omega word so on a word
with infinitely many letters
where the letters are indexed by natural
numbers i don't know why sometimes
people write
n and sometimes people write omega
people like myself i
i think it's kind of random at least for
me but
for words you use the word expression
omega 1. and
the semantics are defined as follows you
uh you uh
a non-deterministic automaton accepts an
omega word
if there exists a run and the runs are
defined in the way as for
non-deterministic finite automata
but the acceptance criterion is that the
accepting state so in this example the
blue state appears
infinitely off so if you think about
this particular
example automaton if you view it on a
as an automaton over a finite words it
will accept all finite words
because you can have for every finite
word you can have a run
where you just use the red state all the
time and then when you are reading the
last
letter you go to the blue state so that
the words have to be non-empty actually
and uh then if you view it as a non
as a automaton so you run it over omega
words
then uh if you will you eventually if
you want to
use the blue state infinitely often
where you have to use it at least once
so what you do is you read some letters
which are either a or b and then you
non-deterministically at some point
decide to go to the blue state
but then you're only allowed to read a
letters so
the recognized language is going to be a
a or b a finite number of times and then
from some point on
you only have a letters and the
corresponding runs will
be obtained by staying in the red prefix
for some time and then switching to the
blue
state any moment after the last b has
been has been written
this doesn't have you don't have to
switch as a
when the last b is ready you can even
consume some a's if
it is some a's if you want to and then
switch to the blue part
actually this particular example is a is
a non-deterministic
automaton that cannot be determinized so
the corresponding language so from some
point on a's omni
this language of omega words cannot be
recognized by any determinants it could
be
automaton so it is it is not a
coincidence that i wrote
non-deterministic
automata because these are the more
important model and the deterministic
automata are weak now in his proof
uh he will introduce this automata he
didn't use the word automaton he he
represented them as some kind of normal
formal logical formulas but
now people think about them as automata
and he
uh showed well although they did not
determine as i mentioned
but the non-deterministic ones are
closed under union under intersection
this is
easily shown using a product
construction a projection this is a kind
of
easy it's always easy for
non-deterministic automata because
if you project a bigger alphabet to a
smaller alphabet
and you are given an input word over the
smaller alphabet then you can use
a non-deterministic to get guess the
bigger
the corresponding letter of the bigger
alphabet and and
and and read that so non-deterministic
autonomous are always going to be easily
close on the projection
but the hard part now is since we are
not allowed to have deterministic
automata is to prove
that they are closed under
complementation and uh
he did show that this is the principal
technical contribution of his paper
and he proved this using the ramsey
theorem and maybe uh
you might have some more discussion of
these topics in
in ordnance tutorial about automata so i
will not go into that
and and this way did he prove that the
mso theory of the natural numbers
decided but
again very importantly he did this using
the automata method and the
corresponding automata have also been
and in a study as a subject of in
intense study later
now the next stage is a famous theorem
of michael rabin which says that the mso
theory and the corresponding automata
method it works not only for the natural
numbers
but it works for the infinite tree so
let me
explain what that means so you can
formalize it as follows
so consider the structure where the
underlying it's also an ordered set but
now it is not totally ordered
now it is well
it is you can think of it a a a as a
tree i will explain why in a moment
and michael raven proved that the mso
theory here
is decidable and that there are
corresponding autonomous
so why do i call it the tree and what is
this structure
well the elements of the structure are
bit strings
and they are ordered by a prefix
relation so this
can be easily interpreted as a tree the
root of the tree is an empty string
then it has two children and standing
for one letter
with strings and then each pitch string
can be extended by adding one appending
one letter in two possible ways and
hence you have
a a tree it's an infinite tree and
the order here is the prefix ordering
now you can think about the order
natural numbers as as being a branch
industry say the leftmost branch and and
you can for example
so so you can embed uh ms over natural
numbers into a
into mso over this in infinity tree
uh uh here in order just to save space
i i equipped a a tree uh with just
the order relation and there is no such
thing as a left child or a right child
uh although with [ __ ] strings it do
have a left and right child structure if
you think that zero is to the left of
one but this is not a an important
omission
because you can write in an mso formula
you can guess using existential set
quantification
a set of vertices which are called
left children and then
verify that have correctly checked by
saying that every for every node there
exists
one child which is a left child from
your guest set and
and one side which is not in the set and
then
use this this set as your notion of left
child it will not necessarily correside
with
zero and one but that's not important
anyway so this is the the the structure
of the
the the tree uh the infinite tree i i
would call it the raven tree of
of uh it has a root and then every note
has two children
and it is ordered by the prefix rule and
what uh rabin proved is that the mso
theory of this structure is also
decidable raven's proof
did use a
notion called raven tree automata but
uh i will describe to you uh a a similar
and and more commonly now used notion
called a
parity automata i will not give the the
proof because it is
rather complex but i will at least say
what are the main ingredients
so the kind of automaton that is used is
called the non-deterministic parity
tree automaton and how does it work
well first of all i have to tell you
what a tree automaton is
so a tree automaton works as follows
if you have a word automaton then a
transition
it looks as follows you have an input
letter you have the state before you
read it and you have the state
after you read it so a tree automata is
a natural generalization
where you imagine that you start the
automaton in the root
and then you have the state p before you
read the letter and then once you read
the letter you branch
into the state in the left child and
state
the right type so a a transition instead
of being a pair of states and a good
letter it is a triple
of states and an input letter
and i would be caring mainly about
non-deterministic parity
non-deterministic automata here
if they're deterministic then
there are several variants of
deterministic one such as it does it is
a deterministic bottom up or top-down
but i will not discuss this right now
and what is the parity condition well
this is
it turns out that if you take a
non-deterministic tree automata with a
biki condition so we have an accepting
set of states
uh then that is not going to be
expressive enough
to cover mso but there is a
generalization called parity which does
the job
and it works as follows so in the
automaton instead of having an accepting
set of states and the requirement then
being that you see an
accepting state infinitely often you
have a more complicated acceptance
condition
and in the parity condition it's called
a peri it's given by a parity ranking
function which assigns to each state a
number
and then a a ram
a run is considered accepting a well in
a tree
automaton it's considered accepting if
for every branch of the tree so like
every a sequence of nodes obtained and
by starting in the root and taking a
child
child child child child so that's a
branch so for every branch in the tree
if you look at the maximal uh
stay rank that appears infinitely often
then it has to be
accepting and accepting here means an
even rank so
zero good one bad two good one three bad
and so on
so the first time you see a parody
condition it might strike you
as a bit artificial but it turns out to
have
a central importance in the theory of
automata over infinite objects
as you will find out later on during the
tutorials
of this bootcamp so that's a
non-deterministic automaton and you use
it to recognize a
property of infinite trees where an
infinite tree
it's a it's it's a it's a raven tree
with with notes labeled by some finite
alphabets so in other words a function
from
0 1 star to the finite alphabet
and using a standard automata
constructions
you can show that languages of
infinite trees which are recognized by
parity throughout them that are closed
under
union intersection and projection well
if you have to deal with the parity
construction it's a little bit
uh uh there's a little bit of a talent
for say a
intersection but you can you you can
deal with it projection is the usual
non-deterministic thing and
union is is even simpler because if you
have to
uh automatically you can just uh take uh
write them side by side and then
and then the recognized language is
going to be union however
complementation is problematic and the
the main technical content of robin's
paper was approved that
well non-deterministic shelter in his
case it was
the uh not with the parity condition but
with
the raven condition but that's uh that
that is very similar
that they're closed under compliment and
and and this is
the main parts of raven's theorem and
the way you would probably the the
uh prove it nowadays is you would go
well not to deterministic automata
because unfortunately there's no
known and it doesn't seem to be possible
to have a good deterministic
model for a tree automata but you use a
different model called alternating
parity tree automata and these are
defined well if you're familiar with
alternating automatic and so to guess
what they would be
and uh these have the nice they're by by
their triggering close under boolean
operations especially complementation
and
then the main
technical work is to show that the two
models are equivalent
and well non-deterministic is a special
case of alternating but
the the the main content of of radiance
theorem is to prove that you can
de-alternate parity
tree automata and and this is something
that
uses two important automata results one
which is that
automata and omega words can be
determinized and not using the
condition as i mentioned before but
using the if you use the parity
condition it works
and uh then the second important thing
is there's a game aspect to it which
will be uh
discussed i i guess in the tutorial by
marci so if you put all of these
ingredients together
it's a highly non-trivial result then
you get a raven's theorem that
these regular languages the automata
since they're equivalent they they have
all the closure properties of mso
and hence you can compute for every mso
formula
uh with three variables and an automaton
which
recognizes the corresponding language
and thus decide the theory
and this is a very powerful result which
which can be used to to obtain
it generalizes all of the previous ones
and it can be used to obtain
many decidability results
and i i i guess that you might uh find
out more about
how this is actually done enormous talk
and now let me move to the last
example of a structure with decidable or
not decidable
mso theory and this in fact is going to
be a negative example
and so it's uh it shows like
where problems start to appear this is a
remarkable theorem uh which says
that the if you take the ordered real
numbers so you like you generalize from
the ordered
natural numbers to the real numbers then
you get an undecidable mso theory
now this i think is kind of strange
so for example if you uh if you think
about first orders here it's not mso
theories
uh then uh the real numbers and the
rational numbers i have the same
first satisfy the same first order
formulas or well sentences
it's easy to see you can play an iron
voice tracks again between the two
but this does not extend to mso theories
and
in in fact for example the basic
property
defining almost properties of the real
numbers such as saying that every set
has at least upper bound
this is an mso uh sentence which is true
in the real numbers but not true in the
rational
uh numbers so there seems to be
something uh going on but you would ex
would think
that maybe it's not such a big
difference but in fact it's a huge
difference
uh so it's a result that was proved
originally by sherlock in 1975
that the mso theory of the real numbers
before there is undecidable
his original approved assumed account a
continuum hypothesis
but later on in the 1980s in work
together with
eureka it was it was shown that the
continuum hypothesis is not necessary
to prove this result and this is a a
a a a very difficult to prove i i will
not even present the
main ideas in it uh what what what
shellac manages to do
is to uh to encode numbers and addition
inside real numbers inside sets of real
numbers
and the only uh available structure is
the order
now this is a bit strange because
there's not much
you would uh if you try to extract any
arithmetic from the real numbers in
order
it would be very hard to do so here is a
is
a witness of why it should be hard so
consider
an mso formula over the real numbers of
order we have just one free variable
that's first order
what properties of a real number can you
express
well actually really nothing you can
just say true or false
and the reason is very simple because
suppose you have a formula
of mso which is true for x equals 5.
then i claim it's going to be true for
every other x and why is that
because you can map the number 5 to any
other real number
using any order preserving bijection of
the real numbers and and since the
the there's a every number can map to
another one
using an order preserving by jackson and
order place everything by jackson also
known as automorphisms of the structure
will uh preserve the truth value of a
first order
formula it turns out that if your form
is true for five then it's also true for
seven
pi i or whatever other number
so whatever a proof you're going to have
such as
shadow did then it's going to uh have to
be invariant under that
automorphism and as i just mentioned
they can take any number to any other
number
but and these automorphisms really kill
first of their logic but if you go to
monadic second order logic they do not
kill it anymore
though why why it's not not so easy to
see and the proof as i said is
complicated
a second counter point is that the
mso theory of the rational numbers with
order is
decidable and uh it is maybe uh nice to
see this as an application
of of raven's theorem because if you uh
think about the raven tree you can view
it as natural numbers
why there are rational numbers why well
uh you can just order the notes of the
raven tree uh
by just appear to the left on the
picture
so what does that mean that means that
we have a node of raven's tree
then all of the elements of its left
child left subtree
are before it and all of its elements of
its right subtree are after it and
if you consider the order defined this
way and then
you will easily see that it's a dense
ordering it's countable and it
doesn't have any end points and it is
well known that
if you take any order which is downs
countable and has no
end point then it is isomorphic to the
rational numbers so this way
uh you you you get the rational numbers
inside the
radians tree and you can you can use a
raven's theorem to decide that
uh this this particular construction
uses the notion of left and right but as
i mentioned before in my
tutorial you can uh encode the notion of
left and right by
just guessing uh an extra set in ravens
is here
in the raven tree which represents the
left children
uh so this way we can see that using
gradients
theorem we can decide that the mso
theory of rational numbers
there is an alternative method which
does not go through raven's theorem and
was actually
originally proposed in in sherlock's
paper and later developed
by by cartoon
call combined who is using a semi
groups for rational numbers but
instead of automata but i will not go
into that
in fact it's an interesting case because
there is as far as i know there's no
no no known notion of automata
for rational numbers so the the existing
methods they need to avoid this uh
either by going into a richer structure
of trees where you
do have automata or by developing a
semi-group
methods over the rational numbers
themselves
so this this uh this uh this theorem
shows
what are the limits of the automaton
method uh so for for example
for the ordered real numbers the msl
theory is undecidable
and this brings me to the conclusion
of the first part of my tutorial where i
gave you
examples of structures where the first
order theory or the
monadic second order theory were
decidable and
uh my main focus was to uh
choose structures so so that that the
decidability of the theory would follow
from
a translation of formulas into
equivalent
automata and now in the later
second and third parts of my talk i will
discuss
applications of of these methods and
others to to
to the satisfiability problem and also
to the
variant of the model checking problem
where the
formula is fixed thank you
you